hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in book 8 of his institutes John Cassian
is going to talk about one of the common
mistakes that he sees monks making with
respect to their own disposition towards
anger anger specifically at their
Brethren and people who they are
connected with but this is something
that we could certainly extend to
everybody this is a great set of lessons
that he is imparting and if you could
place it under one heading you could
call it if I could only get away from
these people I wouldn't get angry and
everything would be just fine and so he
begins this by saying sometimes when we
have been overcome or Mastered by Pride
superbia or impatience
right a something that is directly
connected to anger uh we want to improve
and I love this translation here our
rough and bearish manners right the
Latin for that is so the word for
manners is more race which does mean
manners but also dispositions in
conditos
so you know kind of rude rough but also
inordinate on unorganized you know
undirected in the right way are
dispositions when we want to work on
those then one of the Immediate
Solutions we come up with is well what
if I did you know a retreat I got away
from this I didn't have to deal with all
of these people if I could just like
find myself a happy place to be in then
everything will be great I won't be
upset with people like that and he says
that
this is as if we should find the virtue
of patience there out out in the desert
for example where nobody provokes us but
what we really need to do of course is
develop that virtue of patience it's not
something we're going to find going
somewhere it's not something that we can
gain just by changing our circumstances
by eliminating stressors by spending
more time on self-care pick whatever
other recourse you want the key here is
that we think that if we can just get
away from those people who tick us off
then we're not going to get upset
anymore and Cassian says well that's not
really a solution why not he says we
apologize for our carelessness right but
we don't really take responsibility we
say I messed up I slipped into anger who
do we blame it on we say the reason or
the cause literally of our disturbance
our commotio our passion right other
people are the cause of that
specifically other people's faults or
vices the bad dispositions that they
have and he says that we say you know it
doesn't spring from our own impatience
but the fault of our Brethren and so we
lay the blame on other people and if we
do this if we're making excuses for
ourselves based on Shifting the
responsibility to other people then
we're actually not going to develop the
virtue of patients that we ought to have
in order to deal with and perhaps not
even have to deal with not feel
anger and so he goes on and he says
listen our Improvement and our Peace of
Mind those are supposed to depend on us
we're the ones that are supposed to
build that within ourselves it's not up
to other people to accommodate
themselves to our angry disposition if
we expect that we're actually allowing
them to reinforce that very disposition
and so you know he goes on he says it
must not be made to depend on another
person's will and he's not using the
term voluntas there but arbitriam which
means you know something like another
person's choices so if we are going to
justify ourselves well I got angry but
it's because so and so did that thing
that pushed my buttons Cassian would say
well okay that that's probably true in a
causal way but why are your buttons so
easy to push
maybe you should have a cover over your
button or maybe it would be better if
you didn't have that button at all
wouldn't it maybe that's something you
need to work on yourself so he says the
fact that we're not angry us not getting
angry
right should not be the result of
another person's Perfection it's crazy
to expect other people to be perfect
when we're not perfect either
but it should come from our own virtue
what virtue specifically the virtue of
potsiencia which we translate as
patience being able to put up with other
people without having that anger
response or getting that anger response
under control so expecting
not to get angry you know to depend on
other people's Perfection is basically
condemning yourself to getting angry and
not making any progress towards the
virtue that you yourself
ought to have and you know he says that
monks say this sort of thing so do
Ordinary People and this is a pretty
problematic so he goes on and he says
that
it's those who are perfect and purified
from all fall throughout to seek the
desert who should go off into the desert
the people that are already ready for
the desert not people who as he says
shouldn't be going into Solitude or the
desert uh should not be a cowardly
flight
running away as we say from things you
don't run away into the desert because
you're bringing yourself with you into
that desert and you know a lot of people
might also run away not necessarily even
into the desert but into religious life
I'm going to become a monk and then
everything will be straightened out if
you read much monastic literature you
see that that doesn't solve the problem
for people who have serious vices and so
he says that
um you know what should we do we should
first
exterminate all your faults amid the
Assembly of the brethren in congregation
So within a community you could say now
you know a monastic community
probably a little bit better off as far
as dealing with these things you get
some spiritual direction from you know
the Abbott or other older monks you have
a routine that you're supposed to
practice which he discusses you know in
the institutes part of which it involves
engaging yourself with the scriptures
specifically the Psalms the Liturgy of
the Hours and so you know monk should be
developing should be better off but you
know if you don't work you're not going
to do that so you before you go off in
the desert by yourself to be a hermit
uh work on your faults in the real
community of other people a people who
sometimes tick you off people who
sometimes irritate you what should you
go into the the Solitude of the desert
for well he says there's an aim of
divine contemplation right quantum
plazio
trying to engage with God in a less
distracted way and then he says a desire
of Greater insight and so this is
desiderio in tuitas
so to enter into to step into
these more Sublime intuitions these more
Sublime insights about the nature of God
and the universe and all that that's
what you should be going to the desert
to do not just to get away from your own
vices
so he goes on and he says whatever
faults we bring with us uncured into the
desert we shall find to remain concealed
in us and not to be got rid of and then
what happens well just as when the
character has been improved Solitude can
lay open to it the purest contemplation
and reveal the knowledge of spiritual
Mysteries to its clear gaze
It generally not only preserves but this
is a very important point but also
intensifies the faults of those who have
undergone no correction so a person like
he says can appear to himself to be
patient and humble so long as he doesn't
come across any other people but let
them come across other people and this
is going to come out because it's still
within it right he says those faults
will at once appear on the surface which
were lying hid and dash forth to the
destruction of you know the the
charioteer like horses when the
opportunity for practicing them among
people is removed are faults will
increase they will further develop in US
unless we've first been purified from
them and so he talks about the mere
shadow of patience when a lot of people
go out into the desert they go on a
retreat and they pretend like you know
oh yes I'm so patient well it's not
going to be like that when you're
dealing with other people so this is a
big problem
and you know he goes and he says like
um
like poisonous serpents or wild beasts
uh while they remain in solitude in
their own layers they're not really
harmless because they're not harmless
because they're not actually hurting
anybody this results in their case not
from any feeling of goodness but from
the exigencies of solitude and once they
have the opportunity that poison is
going to come forth so in this case it's
a poison of anger if you haven't
developed real patience the virtue of it
then going into the desert isn't going
to help you and one last bit of evidence
for this that I think we could probably
all relate to you know going on say
camping trips or things like that where
we're on our own is that we're not
really Without Anger we're not really
exercising patience why he says that in
the case it's it's not enough to not be
angry with human beings
we recollect he's talking about himself
that when we were living in solitude a
feeling of irritation would creep over
against us for what
now look at the examples he provides
against our pen because it was too large
or too small against our pen knife when
it cut badly and with a blunt Edge what
we want to cut against the Flint if by
chance we're rather late in hurrying to
the reading a spark of fire flashed out
so we could not remove and get rid of
our perturbation of Mind except by doing
what
cursing the senseless matter or at least
the devil things happen and we're like
damn it you know why did this stupid
thing have to be that way why did my tie
not tie itself correctly you know why
did the chalk squeak on the chalkboard
we get upset and as he says
things that are inanimate things that
don't have a voice things that it
doesn't make sense to get angry at
because they're not screwing with us
they're not pushing our buttons they're
not deliberately doing anything because
they don't have Minds
right so you know he's saying that all
these things show us that unless we've
actually dealt with our anger uh he says
a method of perfection it will not be of
any use for there to be a dearth of man
against whom our anger might be roused
if patience has not already been
acquired the feelings of passion which
dwell in our hearts can equally well
spend themselves on dumb things and
paltry objects and not allow us to have
a state of peacefulness or to be free of
remaining false
so you know
it's not helping us to get angry at
inanimate and speechless things that
cannot reply to our curses and rage nor
provoke our ungovernable temper to break
out into a worse Madness of passion if
they're not provoking us what's
provoking us
our own fault of anger inside so
Solitude by itself is not going to give
us patience getting away is not going to
help us get rid of our anger we have to
work on that in the world that we're
actually living in and then Solitude
might actually be of some help to us not
just in dealing with anger but the other
problems as well
so long as we actually you know do the
work that's required instead of blaming
other people for our own
faults including that of anger